hello everybody and welcome to drunk
minecraft where we put our livers on the
line for your entertainment well I'm
gonna leave hook ha ha I'm just kidding
yeah you're did I wouldn't okay he's at
least five more minutes
yeah I'm dedicated to this uh-huh
whatever this is I don't even know what
to say post it tomorrow
I don't know someday they don't even
know what tomorrow is so yeah tomorrow
wink
ha ha and we don't have an objective
this time we build a mob partner I'm
gonna finish this hella house stone
building out fill the glass house
underwater penis rocketship an
underwater clear glass penis house
rocket rocket gym
ah [ __ ] well office give me kiss tends
to make it launch is anything we ever
make not a penis rocket ship this is
very true well there was that time
before like episode for washing fair
question yeah no it's asking it makes
sense that is a good question I mean I
would like to know the answer
else looks like [ __ ] ah so do you so I'm
gonna sit right in I'm gonna make it a
lava filled house is that cool cool yeah
can we put weight in it hey I hate you
hey hey hey zombie all right this is our
door this is hit buck doors wade in an
obvious Fanning fill the house ha ha ha
oh she's just gonna make that happen I
don't know he's easy to why he's in an
innovative he's innovative ado okay
Sherlock of course of course most
innovative haha yes I like this guy oh
hello that's a lot of llama oh no leave
me alone
who wanna wha hmm that's funny
you can't hit me I'm moving too fast you
can't you can't port me oh my god spear
for me Oh mommy
yes yes you really want access the only
side where there is like unlimited hey
guys guys the love all that covers the
ceiling I'm safe in here my god lava
ceiling what we below a ceiling really
I'm coming inside let's see this oh
right here best house ever
I put the doors up this is it boys like
this house I don't know how this
happened I think I might have done that
boy whatever you do don't jump
wow what no no he's got me an obsidian
hahaha oh yes oh my no yeah it's so
perfectly the only way out is the dig
straight down do it you just go into the
house wait it's not a big deal see oh
you're perfectly fine right Bert I'm
cool hahaha
mom oh I mean sorry that was an accident
what what did you do this trap he made
oh god this is a good start this is
better than that other episode we did
right got the one where Mark lost his
keyboard yeah not once he's an idiot
shut up I'm on fire we decided that Wade
dropped oh I forgot I forgot way did
that
that's wasteful hmm
hey what's up you know you really don't
want to do this with me waiting I got
too much armor
I've got nothing I've got no reason not
to started the fight
uh-oh no you came right for me I saw
bark you okay I'm done I'm done okay now
we need to actually do something right
that's what we need to do really wait
really do you want to yeah go start this
again
that do you wanna about time we really
battled Shane
oh yeah Rick you know you're gonna come
back you're what you have so much more
quicker than they that's why I Lori went
with you I know right
she loved my equipment Rick how'd you
hit me from across the way lag okay
truce truce truce Rick we gotta be
frantic Rick was trying to shake your
head but the good is good Bob I suppose
there you guys are idiots
are you still hitting me we had truce
let's try to shake your hand go do this
where's the hug button mmm a bomb wait
would you [ __ ] stop it
fine you [ __ ] I'm gonna die now
oh I thought lobbing it there Wade oh
you got armor oldest son now um I should
be weight-wise I'll be killing me out of
revenge I don't know it does you're a
dumbass you suddenly got a bunch of
armor so I wouldn't oh poor Bob love
just I killed myself I'm protesting
Tibetan style ooh I remember that
self-immolating that's for real not for
realsies just try and get me Wade out
what the hell how did you get me haha
hahaha why hey Bob hey Bob there's some
good stuff over here not taking it not a
dick
oh yeah it's only waved as a dick we had
a truce I know but then zombie gave me
all his equipment and said to get
revenge on you
zombie why we Troost
I can't type I had to listen to him why
I saw a [ __ ] we Troost you're not
you're not on this call zombie get on is
Cole goddamn it Tommy but I got a I've
got all this good stuff Omar you're
screaming at ha they're gonna get a new
sheriff in town
you're on you're really on wait side who
the hell would ever take Wade sided who
thought mark had that coming
come on no one did no one thought mark
and he had a truce shut up you killed me
you kill me in cold blood
you Tom be told me take revenge and what
what what that just breaks our truce huh
wait that just proves what [ __ ] you
really are we have a truce as far as I'm
concerned had a truce now it's no it's
no holds barred oh I'll come kill him
it's all your good stuff it quit me ha
ha let's turn into like the first
episode
you missed it you missed a whole section
there oh wow one thing I should come
check out the inside of our house
I made some improvements haha I look as
good stuff I got what you got what did
he give me stuff just as you killed me
he killed it gave you stuff just as I
killed you
Dobby also put weighed in in oh sorry
mark
herb Bob dick I don't know who you are
but waiting what never mind
hey work go check out the inside of the
house more nights I'm having a showdown
with Wade he doesn't even know what's
coming I built some stuff in there no in
here idiot are you guys so jerk hahaha
no no no no nope nope nope nope oh
you're going down go down
come on ha ha yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
boys anit up get poisoned you dick oh
yeah so much poison I know right okay
now all right truce truce truce what
they just shot miss you said that truce
truce truce truce truce truce truce
truce truce truce truce you don't look
like you're truce in person you asking
for it I didn't think so
all right truce that's true you gotta
get stuff done we can't just keep doing
this you guys are jerks no no I am I'm
trying Bob but hi creeper army
oh holy crap Oh get me out of here give
me our stop poisons time Amy tell me we
will be good oh my oh oh oh there's so
many oh god okay why why one health you
dick you look like a creeper I couldn't
come the difference you're an [ __ ]
Wade you are a strict out-of-control
[ __ ]
you are a straight-up douchebag that was
for shooting the arrow after saying
truth I didn't kill you and you're
lagging because I said it as I said
truth am i lugging that bad you must be
like a good full like three seconds
after no I said it exactly after I shot
the arrow you're just done [ __ ]
everybody out there ways to nestle okay
Bob I want to play with you nope buy my
secret treehouse all right go like it
when we fight Bob you don't want to be
here always to any secret treehouse go
away how long there's more of them I can
see that Wade here here here here here
no I'm going away from you
I just through oh wait why'd you kill me
again I didn't wait white duck Bob where
are you I I'm getting away through armor
shooting away from Wade
he's a death trap I'm in my secret
treehouse you'll never find it I'm going
to try to find it I'm going on I know
where did Bob I'm going to the treehouse
where is it Bob
wait is that it over there oh no you
know what I'm looking at I know about it
though where are you Bob
Hey look I see Bob I'm going where
you're going oh yeah that was it that
was that Bob don't you try to say that I
love your doors locked
yeah dicks hey wait let me try Markham
Bob your tree is not is locked
are you oppa I am on whatever often
maricon mark what come here a second
okay good kill me uh no okay
ah why what what what oh you got in here
I thought that would work I don't know
why Wow
Oh got you [ __ ] I use wasn't many of
those bar I don't but I - yeah [ __ ] oh
what's that wait what's that I said Bob
attacked you oh yeah whatever I blame
you I was trying to give you your stuff
back
you never blame Bob I could never blame
Bob Bob quick get in the house yes look
I'm in I'm in what the hell is wrong
with you okay there you are hey hi wait
wait we'll never find us in here
oh wait hey what's up [ __ ]
ah there's only four there are we
actually doing in I lost I lost all the
wood that I had all we have is ladders
in stone let's go throughs total not I
was ever fighting with hi guys thanks
anyone Bob what are you doing out there
aah running away from you alright so
we're gonna build something else come
here
actually let's go away from the
devastation that is that let's find a
new place to build let's find a new home
on the island
yeah on top of it we really haven't even
explored this island yeah no we've just
been sneaking around here look over the
top of the mountain I like that where
I'm going I'm following how much time do
we have left if team is we good we're
good Oh beautiful
yeah we've been we haven't done it that
means I gotta go then so Bob oh don't be
like that Bob don't be like you were
before don't don't pull away do you know
how you left us with
why I hate you go see what I see
everybody's getting mad I see yeah I see
that everyone watching don't just
remember don't be a Wade don't use it in
regular conversation you don't pull the
Wade don't pull away why is there water
here my gosh holy [ __ ]
I guess it makes it go here so we can
climb faster oh it's a big mountain I
get it is quite large
anyone have any food no I'm starving to
death I'm starving to death
also I'm not I'm perfectly fine maybe
school all that douchebaggery really got
to your hunger Wade
yo being an a-hole kind of gets to you
after a while
nah well I'm not poisoned because you
deserve it as he ran a hole that sounds
about right
and from are you at the top or an income
yep I am what are you guys doing what
are you guys doing all kinds like ll eat
wait what huh huh cuz you're Nate hole
that sounds about right now I can't
climb up there no no do you think bub oh
no no no why are there 2 stone blocks
here well this is I trying to stop the
water so Wade can't get up here good
idea right you yeah yeah yeah like I
like where your head is at oh man oh my
stop I saw sit on this side it's just
too much uh here we go
I think it's stopping now ok wow that
covered the entire ground there with
water damn pond Bagga T that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] of water
no so oh man what really Wade really
really damn it are you trying to kill me
Oh Bobby Wade was trying to kill me
again
please god mode Bob and I relayed see
I'm even in the fire see wait is did the
douche wait is the king of douche are
you god mode Bob where are you mom are
you a time poured it poured it back Hey
we're not killing each other we're being
told I can't I can't hurt wait so would
love us as god mode aren't we we are
being normal
we're being fun you were having a good
time having a good time don't stop me
know having such a ball don't the lies
our love ha ha why is the lava erupting
what the [ __ ] please deck I like how
we're all on this thing now all out so
that we can do something productive
what's up just ah this is not productive
are there spiders what's happened DOM B
gave me spawners spawn eggs oh I have
stuffers huh I intentionally not give
anything yes please hahaha oh you know
why it is wait you don't like it that
way but idiot oh you gotta kidding me
haha are you know I have an iron helmet
if it makes you feel any better I'm not
going back I'm staying here I don't
think you have you guys I'm not going
back
oh really you think you have a choice
but you don't come back Rick are you not
are you not in the mood for some walking
down haha no suddenly way to said I
thought was as if he realized that it's
really I dick move to kill someone all
the time you guys killed me to start
this off no he didn't ever kill you once
until you killed me I know you thought
you kill me but you did I'm actually
remembering now also I died like five
times before anything happened yeah yeah
that's nothing alright hey Mark you know
what's a really useful way to get down
something really quickly jumping in the
lava yeah a lava it's totally like red
water yeah totally sounds about right
hey god mode name oh wait are you God
do you okay oh I don't know am I gonna
regret this I know Oh totally god mode
it Oh everybody except Wade yeah alright
let's let's actually do something like
totes mcgoats let's all hang out around
wait and make him feel bad let's do
something productive I don't have an axe
to build a house oh I have a stone axe
that's dumb Diaby house zombie I can't
get back up there he need to okay we're
not up there well sorry Wade you had
your time
oh god I had my time ah that's how I
never gets to be cool our heart still
belongs to mark oh yeah oh oh yeah and
he did a cat smiley face so you know
he's for real oh yeah everybody knows
that I'm the king
oh yeah oh yeah I get all the good stuff
I get all the pictures where does
getting thing yeah I feel left out I'm
pretty good oh man I don't I don't get
anything oh man yeah you don't wait you
don't I want things you haven't cool
know where Bob arrived people who are
fans of me should show me how much they
like Bob I don't share within it it
should send me fan letters and I guess
they do root for me in the comments so
I'll take that that's true yes okay now
I still feel left out compared to mark
damn but we have 10 minutes fair have 10
minutes to do so where are you guys I
don't even see you anymore I'm watching
this forest burn down lava um um um um
um um um we have the entire mountain of
lava there you are I see you wait and
some graphical errors I want nothing to
do that's why I was saying um I was
inside of the hell that was all in my
soul oh no oh no oh no this doesn't look
good at all why is her sheep in a box
here it's a sheep in a box I want to
preserve his sheep in about an abaya
baby
yeah okay but why I don't know I was
waiting for you to find a keyboard in
the first episodes instead of building a
productive nice house haha
yeah dick yeah hey where are you could
have avoided all this murder if you had
just built the house like if you didn't
snowball the hate it would have been
just fine
yeah wait why do you attract someone
hate naturally yeah why is that Wade I
hate you both see the sea you see he
could have been nice but he chose to be
the Oh much hate so much you guys
weren't praying nice he chose I all I
did was run away and build a tree house
and you came and killed me
oh my they're all the tree house was
there I was trying to get Marcus stuff
back did you kill mark I treehouse was
not there I had to rebuild it because it
had been blown up I love this pickaxe Oh
Oh God Chuck where did that write all
these creepers come from where are you
mark I'm out by the mob farm are you now
man I'm like on the other side of the
island
why oh I see Wade why are you climbing
that mountain weight or that volcano I'm
getting away from you I'm done I'm done
doing done no I got three blocks of dirt
and I'm building it out no more drunk
monkey episode notes the episode where
we all do our own thing really yeah
there you go you guys can do your thing
leave me alone really Wade good I'm
doing my own thing before you did
anything
I'm digging cobble and I'm loving it I'm
building a dirt house on top of the
sound of becoming a hermit living alone
building a treehouse with a [ __ ] far
away from you douche bags
what did I do Bob what did I do I've
been nothing but supportive of you you
killed Wade a bunch of him angry and
then Wade killed me a bunch all that's
true but you can't really blame me for
ways behavior can't I believe I blame
everyone but me for all of this okay all
right you do that Bob I'm gonna dig down
I always do I'm gonna dig down in a blur
of motion an amazing awesomeness and who
want to start the killing who's the one
that had me teleported into a glass box
ami yeah wait Mar you told it to zombie
is the root of all our problems it's no
no no we need we need something yeah
let's gang up
zombies we could we could do so much
yeah Margo I'm gonna go ahead and detail
that idea sorry from the from the off
sorry sorry I'm digging down but I don't
have any torches so I'm kind of hahahaha
I'm kind of well you're digging down
into a pile of suck something like that
zombie could I have some torches please
but it makes it too bicha two torches
into the torches it's it's a tombow
breaker that's not right
that doesn't seem right Oh Oh mother
died oh you got six minutes to do
something and we've done nothing
I'm building a lot of dirt on top of the
mountain I have I have a house now so
team tee time works occur Dan tee time
you know that my [ __ ] I don't know
how really five I mean a hole I'm really
far away from you not only I need to get
out of this hole how do I get out of
this hole I don't even know I'm sin
pitch blackness oh not on knees on me Oh
No
hahaha wrong
oh god I like it oh please don't kill me
like this hahaha gunman uh-oh
so everything went black I can't see
anything oh here we go
oh my things have been broke did I broke
did everything oh my I got a lockout ha
ha ha ha you broke your minecraft broke
everything I'm still working on is this
I was at the epicenter of the explosion
hang on a climb out through this water
yeah every treehouse I make skits make
it gets more and more majestic really
majestic is that what you would call
your treehouse there this is a very
majestic thing
really ah ah my ass bag McGee I didn't
do anything you Bob boy be good to me
what I don't know I didn't do anything
to you either I don't know what happened
I'm what are you I was just making fun
of your misfortune I have such a sweet
house you do not probably really shitty
sorry I lost my kid I did too
we're back now I'm really I'm really
liking this I'm just gonna stay here the
rest of my life where are you I see you
up there
you stayed away from I see up there
you're not welcome TNT on waves house on
the top of the mountain plox pretty
please pretty please blow up dawn I'm
tar Mountain I have a my whole entire
Mountain yep that's about right I like
to look at this this looks good whoa
whoa not to me not to me oh my god
what's happening oh no oh it's coming
it's coming wait it's coming
I got it uh yeah I dare you
I'm falling through them Oh God
everything is wrong oh my god we were
destroying the server at the moment I
think I just got kicked out
Oh Sheree American haha I power just
look sure from this yes I think so
oh this does not look good but I seem to
be God motive oh wow hahahaha people
have been asking for more TNT stuff
because they've been said we we haven't
been doing it enough so I hope this
makes Allah God we should build a TNT
penis and launch me out of it how about
know which I feel like we did that we're
trying to be painfully here Wade oh it's
not but we do it never bid PG it never
will be
to be a you know kid-friendly you know
this is never been a friendly
okay never been what what I can't move
there we go
all right Wade I like what happened to
your non there
I like how over here how much actually
your house is kind of still there just
way up at the top
oh hey look I'm dead oh no still Tim
he's gonna blow up the Sheep paddock no
wow I think zombie is just innocent
discriminately blowing things up now he
has to find me first where are you are
you another secret treehouse I'm in an
even secret er treehouse than before I'm
going to find it Wow what did oh my I
just oh wow what hell happened what the
hell happened I got it oh you got kicked
out so I don't see you I know I just
connected zombie porn me to Bob please
oh don't didn't know what a minute I
gotta find you I gotta find you in a
minute
I gotta uh yeah a minute hey wait me too
I want to say with a swarm ah oh hello
uh Bob what hi what are you here no I'll
see you ha ha where are you where are
you in and he didn't I don't see you I
am breaking into your house oh yes
Bobbitt no no hi I found a mooshroom I
just broke that don't be like that Bob
come on you know you want the company
gamma Bob come on gonna got it really
cool if I was there oh my gosh of it ha
ha ha hey I survived and so did my house
Oh
all right actually out of time we have
finished up and we have accomplished
nothing again
I built a house other way box Alice all
right this is a lovely house Bob but we
are out of time so thank you so much for
watching check out our minecraft
reaction compilation down in the down
below down there we have a reaction
compilation yes we do we do have a
reaction compilation and jmark you
should come inside my house okay and
check the other videos for other stuff
that we've done other videos that I've
done not we but there's where we've
actually accomplished something at any
of them yeah something anyway so thank
you all catalyst so much for watching
oh and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye hi bye bye
you